hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well the first of the ideas of reason
that Kant is going to examine in detail
in the third part of his proma to any
future metaphysics is what is called the
psychological idea or ideas and we
should mention at the very beginning
that there is a bit of discrepancy or
maybe even controversy here are these
plural or is it singular in the German
text it actually says uh Idan right
plural but then there's a footnote which
actually says eay question mark
uh the editor themsel was unsure about
this and it kind of seems like we're
talking about an idea namely that of the
soul but perhaps there's multiple ones
in play here it's clear that in the two
sections that follow that the
cosmological ideas are plural and the
theological idea is singular but it you
know it's quite interesting to think
about this one and perhaps it'll get
clear as we work through it so why the
psychological idea well it does have to
do with substance but it has to do with
the soul the Su in Greek so
psychological actually makes a lot of
sense here and he's going to begin by
saying that people have long since
observe that in all substances the
subject proper that which remains after
all the accidents as predicates are
abstracted hence the substantial itself
remains unknown and various complaints
have been made concerning these limits
to our Insight so a lot to unpack there
for anybody who isn't really well versed
in the history of philosophy what is
Kant talking about so in ancient and
medieval in modern philosophy we have
this notion of substance and there's
different ways of of translating it
there's a long back history that we're
not going to go into about whether usia
is the same thing as substania suffice
it to say that by K time this is a very
well uh
attested notion right and we see in
whether it's you know Renee Dart or John
lock or or other
people that there are different things
that are being called substance um the
idea that substance is that which
remains after you take away all of the
properties or qualities or predicates
it's the subject the
know certain substances like deart with
the thinking substance that is ourselves
or Renee deart as well so there's a
couple different things going on here we
have the notion of subject and
predicate and you know we don't always
use this today but in K's time this is
quite common an approach it's even used
in metaphorical ways as well and then we
have the notion of substances something
which is enduring or permanent something
that is
lasting and you know lock would you know
try to say well what is the substance of
gold you know it's what remains after
all these properties are taken away and
K goes on and he says we should consider
the human understanding is not to be
blamed for its inability to know the
substance of things that is to determine
it by itself but rather for demanding to
C recogniz it determinately as if it
were a given object it being a mere idea
it meaning substance now a mere idea is
a being of Reason a concept of reason
it's not something that can be grasped
or verified in the scope of our
experience right it pertains to the
completion the totality of of our
experience so it cannot be encountered
anywhere in experience he says pure
reason requires us to seek for every
predicate of a thing its own subject so
this cont saying this is inherent in
reason anything that we can say about
something we need to have some subject
that it it is predicated of and for this
subject which is itself necessarily
nothing but a predicate it's subject and
so on
indefinitely but but it follows we must
not hold anything at all which we can
arrive to be an ultimate subject and
that substance itself can never be
thought by our understanding however
deep we may penetrate even if all nature
were unveiled to us so the understanding
can't grasp substance even though
perhaps reason wants it
to but reason perhaps could do this and
here now we see a very interesting move
this is why it's the psychological idea
or
ideas so if we're going to not look at
things outside of ourselves and say ah
there's a substance there's a substance
because we can't get to the
substantiality of the substances what
about looking at ourselves this is the
move that Renee deart makes isn't it
right and many others as
well maybe the ego the the subject that
we are of all these representations the
subject that has reason that has
understanding that has
sensibility maybe
we the
substance we are where we're getting the
idea of substance from he says we appear
to have this substance in Consciousness
B of
ourselves and notice the plural here
isn't that interesting he doesn't say
the consciousness of myself the
consciousness of ourselves which is
supposed to be similar to each other
which makes perfect sense given uh
everything else that Kant has said
before this and what is that
consciousness of ourselves as thinking
subject right the subject that engages
in thought and he says and indeed in an
immediate intuition this is where we get
into trouble right an immediate
intuition says the predicates of an
internal sense refer to the ego the the
I as a subject so if I say I think that
uh Kant is a really insightful thinker
or I think that he's wrong about
something that I is the subject and
thinks that can't etc etc is the
predicate and so anything that is an I
think and if if if we're adopting you
know Renee dart's famous enumeration of
the different modes of thinking that we
find in meditation to a thing which
affirms which uh denies which doubts
which Wills which Wills against so we
could go on and on and on right all of
those are predicates of the subject that
is the what K is calling the ego the eye
here and so he says I cannot conceive of
myself as the predicate of any other
subject so it looks like we've arrived
at an absolute subject he says we have
completeness in reference in relation to
given
Concepts as predicate to a subject and
here he says not merely as an idea which
is for reason but is an object and
notice that he doesn't use the word
object but he uses gagin which just
earlier in the uh leadup to this he's
distinguished between these two and said
that you know um the ideas don't
actually refer to objects in this sense
but rather represent to us Oba not
gend and so uh he says that not merely
an idea but an object that is what I am
what you are the absolute subject itself
and this seems to be given in
experience what kind of experience the
experience that I have of my own
thinking the experience that you have of
your own thinking the experience that to
go back to the we here we have as human
beings of Our Own own thinking of
thinking along with this long Dead Guy
Emmanuel Kant right so it seems like we
now have a way to get at the absolute
subject we are wrong to seek it outside
of ourselves instead we should find it
in ourselves in the soul in what is
lasting
right so he goes well this expectation
is disappointed this isn't going to work
why not the ego is not a
concept right it's not a
be um and so he says that it can't be a
predicate but it also cannot be the
concept of the absolute
subject right it's only the indication
of the object of the internal sense so
far as we cognize it by no further
predicate it cannot be a predicate of
any other thing but it can't be a
determinate concept of the absolute
subject but is only the reference of the
internal phenomena to their Unknown
Subject and he calls this a regulative
principle and so there's a very natural
misunder understanding which infers the
nature of the soul from this
supposed cognition of the substance of
our thinking being and he says well this
is
specious because the the knowledge of
this substance would be outside of the
complex of experience now notice what
he's saying there the complex of
experience not just experience an
individual experience but the totality
of experience we can't experience the
absolute uh subject as the ego
so that's not going to work and then he
goes you know we might call this
thinking self the soul substance being
the ultimate subject of thinking which
cannot be represented as the predicate
of another thing but it's quite empty
and inconsequential if permanence
Bahar right a endurance a
perdurance uh if this is not um part of
it can't be proved of it and and now
there's a little bit of
a
mistranslation here misleading
translation the quality which renders
the concept of substances and experience
fruitful there is no German term here
corresponding to Quality that's been
read in by the translator so that could
be a little bit misleading because
equality would be a predicate right so
we don't want to think of it in that
terms we want to say that what makes a
substance substance is indeed
permanence but if
it well Kant goes on and he says
permanence can never be proved of the
concept of a
substance as a thing in itself so if
we're considering our our soul as a
thing in
itself if we're considering external
things as things in themselves we can
never prove permanence of any of them
and yet and on the other other
hand it could be proved at least for the
moment
inexperience right because that's where
we can register these things so you know
that's important and then Kant is going
to say okay I'll go with you on that
however there's two problems one of
which he's going to talk about in terms
of the soul the other of which he's
going to address more widely in a
footnote so can we say that the soul
really is permanent within the realm of
experience it's hard enough to get
experience of the Soul anyway but he
goes on and he
says
um here we go from the concept of the
Soul as a substance if we would infer
its permanence this can hold good as
regards possible experience only not of
the Soul as a thing in itself and beyond
all possible experience okay so so far
so good this is what we've already
said life is the subjective condition of
all our possible
experience consequently we can only
infer the permanence of the soul in
life for the death of man is the end of
all experience so
now we could say well wait a second what
if you outlive somebody else well this
idea of grasping the soul and
experience that really only works for
yourself like a firstperson
perspective so even if I see somebody
else living and dying and they
communicate a lot to me I can't like
peer into their soul I'm not having
their
experience it's only mine right and so
while I'm alive sure I can say yeah I'm
the same guy I'm the same
substance while I'm alive having
experience soon as I die I'm not having
experience anymore there's no me there's
no ego no to have that any longer so he
says the death of man is the end of all
the experience that concerns the soul as
an object of experience unless you prove
the contrary and that would be circular
because that is exactly what we're
trying to figure out so he says the
permanence of the Soul can only be
proved and no one cares for that it's
not helpful during the life of man but
not as we desire to do after death why
the concept of
substance in so far as it's to be
necessarily combined with the concept of
permanence can be so combined only
according to principles of possible
experience therefore for the purposes of
experience only
so we can't get an immortal Soul as a
permanent
substance um we can't actually say even
that the soul completely disappears it's
a blank right then there's a really
interesting
footnote and in this some of our worries
about well wait a second how do we
experience substance are coming to the
for so Kant says it's indeed remarkable
how carelessly metaphysicians have
passed over the principle of the
permanence of substances without
attempting a proof of it why because
they found themselves abandoned by
proofs as soon as they began to deal
with the concept of substance common
sense or rather little bit better
translated common understanding right
firstand um Common Sense which felt
distinctly that without this
presupposition now presupposition is
something that you're assuming no Union
of perceptions and experiences possible
supplied the want the manga by a
postulate right so it IT projects
something rather than actually proving
it and it projects this postulate of the
permanence of
substance and it says it couldn't derive
this from experience because why not you
never have experience of anything that
actually is permanent how could you
because you only experience this much of
you know time before time afterwards I
mean you might say well that mountain
over there is permanent what does
geology tell us no they're not they came
into being at a certain time H maybe
they're permanent after that mountains
aode nothing is really
permanent in in that sense no object
that we can encounter within the realm
of our experience and if you think about
our own very limited experience we can
say well you know I've had this book for
years and years and years that doesn't
mean that it's permanent throw it in the
trash let it go into a landfill get
chewed up get eaten by something the
substance is permanent the the paper is
still there the paper's made of wood and
ink right that stuff can be transformed
into other well the you know atams
themselves are permanent well we're not
talking talking about atoms right now
are we you're not going to have an
experience of an atom so he goes on and
he says um from experience itself it
could never derive such a principle
partly because material objects cannot
be so traced in all their alterations
and dissolutions that the matter can
always be found undiminished partly
because the principle contains necessity
which is always the sign of an AR priori
principle now K says you can't actually
have these AR pror principles but those
are categories of the understanding or
pure concepts of the understanding those
are not something that you actually
encounter in experience
itself so you know this would apply to
material objects just as much as to the
soul as well and so that's that's an
important thing to think about he also
talks about external and internal
experience and he's talking about um
things that are real out side of us
which correspond to our external
perceptions and he says
that this can be in fact proved to be
not a connection of things in themselves
but for the sake of experience so long
as we're not trying to say that we grasp
things in themselves but we stick within
the realm of experience we can say Yeah
we actually intu it things in space and
time both externally in terms of objects
that that are there for us and
internally our own grasping of our S as
the the ego the person that continues on
and being so he says by means of
external experience I'm conscious of
actuality of bodies as external
appearances in space in the same manner
as by means of internal experience I'm
conscious of the existence of my soul
and time but this soul is cognized only
as an object of the internal sense by
appearances of shinan that constitute an
internal State and of which the being in
itself which forms the basis of the
appearances is unknown and so he's going
to be here criticizing and rejecting
what he calls cesan or interesting uh
turn of phrase material idealism deur
quite famously said you know external
substances we can know something about
them but not all that much but but
myself as a mind I can know myself right
I can know all sorts of things about
myself then there's God as a third kind
of substance we can't know that much
about God but enough to get the the
project going right so he says cartisian
idealism does nothing but distinguish
external experience from dreaming and
the Conformity to law of the former that
is external experience from the
irregularity and false illusion of the
latter in both it presupposes space and
time as condition of the existence of
objects only inquires whether the
objects of the external senses which we
when awake put in space are actually to
be found in it as the object of the
internal sense the soul is in time that
is whether experience carries with it
sure criteria to distinguish it from
imagination and Kant says this can be
disposed of we already do that in common
Life by investigating the connection of
appearances in both time and space
according to what he's discussed earlier
in the work universal laws of experience
so he says material idealism is very
easily
refuted um and and you know we don't
have to go down de cart's path he says
that uh the ego in the proposition I am
means not only the object of internal
intuition but also the subject of
Consciousness what it is that is
conscious what
underlies
Consciousness and uh this is kind of
analogous he says to um the you know the
question of bodies as appearances of the
external sense exist as bodies in nature
apart from my thoughts right um and he's
going to say that the question whether I
myself as an appearance of the internal
sense in parenthesis the soul according
to empirical psychology exist apart from
my faculty of representation in time is
an exactly similar question and must
likewise be answered in the negative so
I am not two separate things the faculty
of representation in time and the
appearance of the inner self the soul of
uh empirical psychology I'm just what I
am and he says um the formal which I've
called
transcendental uh actually abolishes the
material or cartisian
idealism right so um we we don't arrive
at a
knowledge of the Soul as the subject
right as some sort of enduring or
permanent
substance but we do have this as an idea
and we want to be careful that we don't
get misled in into attributing more to
the soul than we are
warranted in affirming of it it's an
idea it's not an object a reality that
we could know exhaustively so this is
the psychological idea or ideas the
first of the transcendental ideas that
Kant is going to discuss in the third
part of the
proma